let's discuss interest groups and as you
can see here it is one of the three
parts of the Iron Triangle that we first
studied when we looked at the
bureaucracy in the executive branch and
the whole point of the Iron Triangle is
to show how these different parties can
influence each other and so just as a
reminder an interest group is any
collection of folks who organize in
order to advocate for something in
public policy this could be groups of
corporations it could represent an
industry it could represent a social
cause and we're going to look at some
major interest groups in the United
States in a few minutes but some can be
quite large and some can be quite small
but what you see from the Iron Triangle
is how these parties can influence each
other an interest group can give
electoral support to a member of
Congress by getting its members to go
out and vote for that member of Congress
or maybe even doing advertising for that
member of Congress or giving direct
financial support in exchange they might
get friendly legislation and oversight
and that'll happen because the Congress
person who got that support from the
interest group might have a friendly ear
to that interest group and it might be
open to hanging out with lobbyists from
that interest group the term lobbyists
or lobbying is believed to originate in
17th century England where people who
wanted to influence members of
parliament would hang out in the lobby
of the parliamentary building waiting to
talk to those members of parliament and
that's what essentially lobbyists do
today they try to meet with Congress
people or meet with the staff of
Congress people and try to influence the
types of bills that are introduced to
Congress for consideration and how
various members should vote for those
bills now bureaucracy these are the
folks who for the most part of doing the
work of actually running the government
and they have influence and they can
dictate what regulations are going to be
who gets various contracts and so you
could imagine that might be of interest
to interest groups now to make tangible
what some of these interest groups are
you have entities like the afl-cio which
stands for the American Federation of
lay
Congress of Industrial Organizations and
this is a meta organization of a bunch
of labor unions and as you can imagine
they're going to advocate for labor
friendly policies it might be things
that favor the manufacturing industry or
that favor employees rights to
collectively negotiate with their
employer it might be advocating for
trade policies which would be perceived
as more friendly to the American worker
its membership is roughly twelve and a
half million people and so just getting
them out to vote can have a significant
influence on elections you have groups
like the US Chamber of Commerce and
what's interesting here this membership
of over three hundred thousand this
isn't just individuals this includes
corporations even though the Chamber of
Commerce does not have the biggest
budget of the groups we're gonna look at
it is actually consistently the biggest
lobbying group spending most of this
money on lobbying and they're going to
try to advocate for business friendly
policies in our government you have
groups that advocate for social causes
like the n-double-a-cp they don't have a
huge budget but they are considered very
very influential when it comes to issues
surrounding minority rights you also
have very influential groups like the
National Rifle Association and when we
compare the NRA to some of these other
groups it's interesting to think about
the number of issues they concentrate
their efforts on for example the Chamber
of Commerce might be thinking about a
very broad array of policy decisions
that might affect commerce that might
affect businesses while the National
Rifle Association and its members and
this is a significant membership here is
likely to be much more focused on a
narrower set of issues around gun rights
and gun ownership you have the American
Medical Association which despite its
relatively small membership here is
highly highly influential because these
240,000 people are for the most part
physicians who many of us are very used
to listening to you have the American
Association for Retired professionals
which has a membership of 37 million
people and a budget of 1.6 billion so
these entities can be
very large and very very influential now
as I mentioned not all of these dollars
go directly to lobbying they could be
spending money on voter education they
could be spending money on legal funds
to advocate for cases that are in their
interest they could be giving direct
support to various candidates or to
various parties they could be
advertising in the media for their cause
but if we think about direct lobbying
this chart right over here is quite
interesting
it comes from opensecrets.org and if
you're really intrigued by understanding
more of how money and influence come
together in American politics I
encourage you to go to their site but
this is a list in 2017 of the top
spenders in lobbying in the United
States and as I mentioned you see here
at the top the US Chamber of Commerce at
eighty two million dollars and this
isn't even the most they've ever spent
in a year there are some years where it
is well over a hundred and fifty million
dollars that they've spent the National
Association of Realtors the Business
Roundtable pharmaceutical research and
manufacturers of America and this money
is for the most part to pay lobbyists
who will meet with members of our
government to directly advocate for
certain policies now an interesting
thing to think about is what positive
things might be done by interest groups
and what potentially negative things
might be there and how equitable is this
system the positive things folks could
argue are hey they could work on voter
education many issues that policymakers
are trying to decide on are quite
complex so it might be good to have
experts weighing in but on the other
hand it might seem like money is
disproportionately influential and that
industries that generate a lot of money
could have a disproportionate amount of
influence and they could potentially use
that influence to further benefit those
industries to give them even more power
and influence so I will let you decide